they say that they're going to release it.
I'm just like, when, please release it for Christmas, please.
That's funny.
There's some large companies out there who are sweating bullets right now,
just knowing that their credit card flow is insecure.
Check out your credit card flow.
Just waiting for the CSS release.
All right, everybody.
How's it going?
Welcome to our last episode of the year.
So we just wanted to give a really big thank you and shout out to everybody from the critical
thinking community.
All of you have been in there from day one up until maybe this is even your first episode.
We just, you know, we can't really thank you enough for everything that you've done.
And it's been amazing to see the community come together and consume our podcasts and
give us feedback and interact with everybody.
And it's just been an amazing year overall.
We definitely couldn't have asked for anything better.
So, you know, shout out to you guys.
You guys made this happen.
You know, thank you to everybody in the discord.
Thank you to everybody on YouTube.
Thank you to everybody on Spotify and Apple podcasts and just everywhere.
It's been amazing to see the outpour from the bug bounty community to our podcast.
And it really just is giving us a signal that we need to keep doing what we're doing.
So, you know, thanks again for all that.
And we're really looking forward to what's going to be coming in the next year.
This episode is really just a very chill sort of recap for me and Justin.
We're going to be going over our sort of year in review, the trends that we had in our own
personal hacking experience, some of the things that we'd like to be doing next year
and moving forward.
And yeah, like I said, thank you to everybody for listening.
Thanks for, you know, sharing the podcast, supporting us.
We really appreciate it.
And we can't wait to see what happens next year.
All right, we're rolling.
So you were saying 10, you have 10 gig now in your house.
Yeah.
So, I mean, technically I'm only getting like 7.8 gig down and like four gig up.
But I mean, it could be worse.
7.8 gig down, is that what you said?
Per second?
Yeah.
Per second.
Holy crap, dude.
What'd you have to do to get that?
They wanted me to sign up.
Honestly, they sent me a letter in the mail.
They were like, hey, we're, you know, we're rolling out.
This guy's a sucker.
They sent out all these things in the mail and they were like, you know, speeds up to 10
gigs.
And I was like, okay, you know, we'll see about that.
It's a local one to the Bay Area called Sonic.
Wow.
That's crazy.
So they, yeah, it's crazy.
So it's, dude, it's $50 a month.
No way.
Oh, I thought you, they were at least priced.
That's, that's cheaper than mine, dude.
That's what cheap.
It's cheaper than what.
So I used to pay for a different ISP.
I used to get 1,000 down and I paid for higher upload speed for 35 megabits.
Up.
Uh, and I, I paid $85 a month for that.
That's what mine is.
Yeah.
And then I got this letter in the mail and they were like, yeah, speeds up to 10 gig.
I was like, okay, yeah, yeah, sure.
Whatever.
I look it up and, uh, you know, they're like, oh yeah, it's available in your area.
50 bucks a month, three months free.
I was like, yeah, okay.
Whatever.
As he types it into the search bar.
Yeah.
I'm like, yeah, we'll see.
We'll see.
The sign up button.
Yeah.
Cause I'm always, I always look for, you know, a better deal if there's one there.
So, um, and sure enough they had it and they were like, you know, here's the status.
We're laying lines.
And, uh, you know, I signed up and sure enough, they, they came and they, they installed like
a fiber termination box and stuff.
I was going to say, did they have to like dig through your whole front yard or something like
that?
No.
So, um, they run the fiber on the poles here.
Uh, cause we don't have like snow or anything like that.
Sure.
And, uh, they basically just teed it off from the pole up to the, like the roof of my house.
Wow.
And then they ran it through my attic and down into my office and they terminated it with
an ONT just like on the wall.
There's like, there's a fiber line like coming through my ceiling.
Did you have to cut, did you have to cut like a bunch of holes in your wall?
No, there's, there's a single drill hole that they put like a little flange around and,
um, the fiber line just like runs along my ceiling, along the wall terminates here.
Cause I don't have ethernet throughout my house.
Otherwise I would've done it somewhere else.
Um, and then it just connects to my server and my server pushes everything out.
It's crazy.
Wow, dude.
That's crazy.
Your, your server rack behind you there has better internet connection than in some freaking
data centers now.
Yeah, dude.
Yeah.
You could probably see it.
So I've got, um, I've got some really fancy, fancy schmancy stuff here.
This is, um, this is a 24 port, 10 gig switch.
Okay.
So it's got 24 ethernet ports and each ethernet port puts out 10 gigs.
It does like 300 gig per second throughput.
Uh, it can do 25 gig service.
It's like all of this recently.
So, so it costs you $50 to upgrade, but then he spent an extra thousand dollars in hardware
in the first week.
Um, yeah, yeah, no, these two, these two are new.
These are, these are new fancy upgrades that I deal with it.
Like, yeah.
So no.
Uh, yeah.
So, so both of my computers, uh, the best adapters that I have do two and a half gig.
So I can saturate those for sure.
Like I've done speed tests on my laptop at like two and a half gig.
Uh, the speeds that I can get that I'm getting right now are coming directly from the gateway.
Um, but, uh, yeah, I have, I have cards adapters coming in the mail that are, that will give
me 10 gig on my devices.
How much did you spend on all of the crap surrounding your new 10 gig upgrade?
Also, you're moving, you're going to be moving in the next, right?
Right.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, so, so here's the, here's the thing.
Um, you ain't going to get the speeds in East coast, man.
It's not going to happen.
Yeah.
I probably won't get the, those speeds from my ISP.
What, what this does do is it gives me internal 10 gig.
So my whole internal network has 10 gig speeds now.
So I can transfer files between my NAS at 10 gig speeds.
I can transfer things between devices, all that kind of stuff at 10 gig speeds, which is
a nice perk.
If you have like a, like a media server or something like that.
Which I do.
Yeah.
Nice.
Um, that's what that is.
Um, and then, uh, the hardware was about $2,000.
Um, Oh my God.
For the upgrade.
Oh, dude.
10 gig stuff is expensive.
That's more expensive than I was thinking, man.
What the heck?
I was, I was getting ready to cringe at you saying $500.
No, no, no.
So, so the gateway, like the gateway, if it was just the gateway, that would have been
500 bucks.
The real expensive stuff is when you start to have like multiple terminations of 10 gig.
So just for some context here, and I know we're rambling a little bit, but Hey, it's
Christmas time.
Like a, like a USB slash Thunderbolt adapter for like a laptop.
So like a Mac, right?
It has all USB-C Thunderbolt, uh, four parts or something.
Yeah.
An adapter for that, that does 10 gig is $250.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
And like the, all the, like the switching, honestly, like the switches and stuff are cheaper
than it is to buy the adapters for the actual endpoints.
Like my PC is going to use a PCI express 10 gig adapter.
That's like $70.
That's not like too bad.
Right.
Like that, that that's doable.
$250 for like, that's, you know, it's crazy.
So some of these things are like really, really expensive just because it's not a widely used
to like most people, right?
Like you can buy two and a half gig adapter readily.
Most people don't need more than two and a half gig.
I contacted my ISP.
Cause I was like, Hey, I got like all my, I got my equipment set up and I did tests and
I'm not getting my full 10 gig speeds.
I'm only getting like seven and a half down and like four up.
And they were like, okay, well like, uh, we're delivering the full 10 to you.
But like, I don't think anybody in your area is going to have anything close to that.
But let me look.
And like, he looked at, he was like, all right, well, nobody has anything close to that.
But like the closest I could find is somebody has an Eero that's got like two and a half
gigs symmetric and they're not having any problems.
So, you know, let me know, like if you find what the problem is, I was like, okay, whatever.
I expect you to go drop, you know, freaking two grand on all the equipment you needed
to like call them out on their bullshit on their 10, 10 gigs up and down.
That's crazy.
Yeah, for sure.
Like, I don't think most people have, have this level of equipment, but, um, you know,
I like, I like fancy toys.
Your, your home setup is pretty bad-ass and your automation set up and that sort of thing.
It's pretty great.
So, uh, definitely makes sense that you would invest in that.
And since we're, since we're already off topic, I might as well take us a little bit further.
Well, this was tangentially on topic that I was just going to talk about a little later.
Um, I'm going to go ahead and share my screen for anyone who is, uh, following along on YouTube.
Um, but do check this out.
So I recently, um, can you, can you see my screen yet?
Yep.
So I recently set up, um, so sort of inspired by your, uh, Python based sort of encoding,
decoding systems, you know, the various modules you've set up over the years.
Um, I.
Um, I told you I was working on my own sort of, uh, keyboard shortcut, um, oriented sort
of utility system.
Let's call it that right.
Where, where, you know, you can do a URL encoding, decoding, base 64, encoding, decoding, and
that sort of thing.
And then I thought, man, this would be really cool if it had a sort of a UI based, um, portion
of it.
Right.
Um, and so I, I found this tool right here.
This is called flow.
Um, and it's like a little launcher and you can program it with Python modules.
And so I wrote a bunch of Python.
I just installed it last night, but I wrote a bunch of Python modules for it.
And one of them is like this, like JWT.
Right.
And then I can paste in a JWT and it will go ahead and open it right away in like JWT
IO or something like that.
Right.
Uh, let me see if I can get it to, to show.
Yeah.
Like this.
And then it'll inject it right into JWT IO to make it easy to see.
Uh, and I've got it like, um, various hex parsing and URL encoding and decoding really quickly.
And one of the ones that I found the most useful is this one.
Check this one out.
So I popped this open and I type M R R right match and replace regex.
And essentially what it'll do is it'll allow me to, uh, specify, uh, in the first parameter
of this, it I'll specify a, um, and for those of you listening, it's just a small box on my
screen that's popping up.
And, uh, I type a little command into it and it will show me the output, uh, in that same
little box or copy it to my clipboard.
So what this one does is it.
Is it does a match and replace regex on what is in my clipboard.
So I can say like, okay, um, let me go ahead and replace every, uh, you know, a
character with a B character.
Right.
And if I like, go ahead and just copy this command and, and run it now, the contents of
my clipboard is M R R B B instead of M R R a B.
Right.
So like all of the time when you're, I'm trying to work on stuff, like I'm wanting to
strip out new line characters or I'm wanting to like, you know, remove every
character that's not a number or something like that.
And then I've got to either do it manually.
I've got to write a little Python script for it.
And now I've just kind of got this really easy plugin based, um, launcher system that
will go ahead and run all of those matching place regexes for me and that sort of thing.
And, or, and remove various, you know, like for example, the scenarios where you need to
remove a backslash, right?
Because you're copying escaped JSON into normal JSON.
So you can do that sort of thing.
Um, and then some of the other things I've got on my list that I haven't fully built out
yet is I want to have it like quick, quick query, um, quick query chat GPT, uh, 3.5 and
be able to do that.
And I also want to be able to have it do OCR automatically where I'll like have a picture
in my clipboard and then I'll just hit like OCR and it will take all the text out of that
picture and copied into my clipboard.
I just feel like that'd be super bad-ass.
All right.
So for OCR, I have a thing for you.
It's, um, there's a tool called power toys.
It's actually written by, I think, by Microsoft.
Yeah.
Power toys run.
So he has, um, there's like an OCR utility built into that.
That's open source.
Um, so have you set up this power toys run thing?
Yeah, I have it.
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
Uh, the other thing, Joe Finney's text grab.
So why aren't you using this for, for your like power toys or flow or anything like that?
For your encoding modules.
Um, so there's a couple of reasons.
Uh, the main thing is it's extra overhead.
So for, for Mac, this reminds me a lot of this, there's a tool called Alfred.
Um, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Alfred, which is a, it's, it's kind of like the, it basically just looks like your spotlight,
but it has a bunch of different tools and you can do all the same kind of stuff.
You can, um, you can, you know, have it run scripts and custom handling and all that
kind of stuff.
It's very, very, very similar.
So I imagine you could probably do the same thing with Alfred on Mac.
Yeah.
Um, for me, I like being able to like chain them together and like have sort of the flexibility
that I have because it's a programming language.
So because I'm doing it in Python, I have all the manipulation factors of like strings and
indexes and lists and like the subtypes, like the, the primitive types and stuff that you have
access to in Python that make it easy to sort of manipulate data in more ways than, um, like
you, you could technically do it with like the setup that you have for me.
I can basically just because their functions, I can just easily like, you know, scrap something
together and it's a little less.
And I guess, uh, you know, yeah.
And, and I guess in a Python context as well, you've got the, you can press the up button
or whatever, and it'll show you the previous command and you can redo the same command over
and over again, rather than having to like save it and then paste it and that sort of thing.
Right.
I'll have to see if my, my flow has like a history thing.
But what I was thinking was like, you could actually just define a query in flow, um, launcher
dude, bagel is this cat.
Yeah.
I don't know if we told people I got another cat.
Her name's bagel.
She's a kid.
And then she's just like the most curious little, she looks like she's hunting something right
now, which is cute.
I can't even deal with it, man.
Interesting.
Yeah.
She's very, very cute.
Um,
yeah, but what I was thinking was like, you could use the, uh, flow, you know, plugin system
to actually just be able to write all of your stuff in the flow, um, in the flow little box
that pops up.
Right.
And then you have it just copy it back to you.
I don't know.
There's something really cool to me about having something in your clipboard and then modifying
it and then, you know, being able to paste it again, uh, or even having it selected and
then you hit something and it does it because it just makes everything a lot more seamless.
I think so.
Yeah.
I was just talking about this.
I was talking about this with somebody else, but I use my clipboard as like a buffer, basically
like a temporary buffer, like all the time.
Um, and I use, especially in Python, there's this, um, this module called Piper clip.
Yeah.
Like it's basically paperclip, but P Y and it's, it's cross platform clipboard reading
and writing and it's so, so useful.
Yeah.
Um, because you, you know, you just from Piper clip and import copy paste, and then you have
two functions copy based and they copy and paste from your clipboard.
And then, uh, you know, I, yeah, it's, it's really, really, um, awesome.
Cause you can change stuff together.
Like you said, you can basically, you know, copy, wrap it around some thing that reads from
your paste and it just transforms your clipboard and, you know, makes everything super, super easy.
So I love that kind of the little flows makes the little helper functions, all that kind
of stuff makes it so much easier.
It really does.
Do you, and I guess just one last question on this note, do you know, if power toys has
the capability to do Python based plugins?
Hmm.
I don't know about that, but the reason I brought up power toys was because power toys
uses the, this OCR project.
And I think I sent it to you, it's called text grab.
Okay.
Um, but you can probably.
Use that because you're on windows.
You can probably use that for the OCR stuff on Mac.
I think there's built in libraries like the, like preview and stuff, you know, like, um,
on Mac, the OCR is like really, really good.
I don't know what they're, what, like, I think it's an internal thing that Apple does, but,
um, it's, it works really, really well.
You can just like take a picture and you can just select text from it.
Oh, just like, oh, like everywhere.
Yeah.
You can just like, you know, open, if you open a PNG on your phone, on your Mac, like it
works the same on all of them.
And basically if there's text in an image, it will just let you highlight it and copy
it out.
And no way.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Oh my gosh, dude.
Frick.
You know, I'm pretty firmly anti Mac, but you've been kind of winning me over, over the
past.
It's really good.
I'm talking to you every week for at least an hour and a half, you know, that there,
there is a lot of stuff that it just comes built in and is simple and easy to use that
I probably would have to go and set up and think I'm so cool for setting up.
But like, then I realize everyone's got this if you're just using Mac.
So yeah.
And like, the thing is, I, I, you know, my powerful computer is mainly my windows desktop,
but I really hate hacking on it because it's like, it's not that you can't set everything
up.
I think like for almost everything, there is a parallel or even just, you can install it
in one way or another using WSL or some windows wrapper of the same tool or whatever, but like,
it's really just having to do that extra stuff of like, does this work on windows?
Is this a windows problem?
Okay.
What do I need to install to make this work on windows?
And now what do I have to do to like make it work within those bounds?
Instead of on Mac, I just feel like most of the time, if it's some sort of Unix based
tool, there's probably a Mac port for it.
If not, I can probably install it from source and I'm going to be good to go.
Like, you know, just like I would be on a Linux box.
And that's like, that just makes things a lot easier to work with, but it's expensive.
It's expensive.
And like, they tend to have sort of planned obsolescence, you know, where, where they're,
you know, after five, six years, your Mac is not going to be as good as, you know, the ones
that are coming out now.
And you're going to want to upgrade.
That's the same case for, for everything, man.
I don't like, I bought a laptop in 2020, like mega powerful three and a half K laptop.
And I was like, this thing's going to last me forever.
And I can rarely use it now.
You know, it's just thing, you know, when we're using it every single day and we're traveling
with it to the live hacking events and that sort of thing, it puts, you put some miles on the
thing and you just got to replace them every couple of years.
I've kind of come to grips with that.
Yeah, for sure.
It's definitely like one of the more unfortunate costs of doing business, uh, within like bug
bounty is that like, yeah, we use expensive high power hardware and we use the shit out
of it and it, it, we burn it into the ground basically.
With, with Kaido now we may not even need to use that high, high expensive, highly expensive
hardware.
Maybe I'll downgrade my Ram amount perhaps.
Seriously, man.
There's no reason I need to have 128 gigs of Ram in this computer that I'm on right now.
It's like, this is ridiculous.
This is overkill from almost everything except for opening just the smallest Burt projects.
So crazy.
Honestly, if, if I could install, if I could have like a hackintosh easier, um, like in an easier
way, I would probably like strongly consider doing that.
I really only use windows for like gaming and I'm like, you know?
Yeah.
Makes sense.
Well, I, I, uh, I just want to bring that back, that conversation back around to bug bounty,
um, about the launcher thing, because I I've used it already today and yesterday, well,
and a little bit yesterday when doing bug bounty related stuff.
And it's so handy for getting, you know, if you have a system in place to be able to
write plugins quickly, to transform data in your clipboard, uh, or transform data that
you're highlighting, or maybe even like Joel does transform data that you're sort of pasting
into a, you know, Python module or whatever.
Um, it really helps your reduce the friction of ideation during exploitation.
And also you just feel leet as heck when you're doing it.
So I would encourage any of you guys when you're like, you know, you're too brain fried
or you're too, you know, in the weeds and you got to step out and do something else for
a little bit.
Maybe you might set up, you know, work on setting up your launcher or your automation
setup, uh, when it comes to this sort of thing.
I think, I think they get value for that.
Yeah.
I will say also like, because of the way that you've set it up where it's, it's
running Python.
Yeah.
That means that it's extensible.
So like you could take the stuff that I'm doing all the functions and stuff that
I've already written.
You could just wrap them in like a, you know, a script that runs that function specifically.
Could you send that to me?
Yeah, no, for sure.
Yeah.
I'll send you, I'll actually send you it.
Cause, um, I'll send you whatever I have.
Um, and you can, you know, you can basically just do that where then if you want to use
them sort of in, um, in like a IPython or in the console, you can do that, but you
can also run them sort of from anywhere.
We should, we should clean it up actually and release it to the, the, uh, critical thinkers
tier on discord.
I think they'd probably really like that.
Yeah.
That'd be good.
I'm super down.
Yep.
I have a module called pie hacks.
So I'll, um, I'll send it over to you.
Sweet.
That sounds good.
Um, all right, well, we're already 20 minutes in and we haven't even covered any of the things
that we were going to talk about.
So let's get to the news.
Um, nice old fashioned, Justin and Joel style episode this time around, we've been doing
a lot of guests and, uh, you know, masterclass and all sorts of special stuff lately.
So, um, good to get back to the, the good old Justin and Joel structure.
Um, yeah, absolutely.
Um, the, the thing that I had first on the news for today was the CTF by Franz Rosen that
went out December 15th.
Um, there has been a revival of CTF, uh, particularly XSS CTF on, on Twitter.
We see a lot of, of, uh, releases from, uh, Joe X car, um, and Franz and Matthias.
And I did one or two.
Um, so it's really cool to see those come back.
And this one that Franz did was definitely something I've never seen before.
I actually didn't have the chance to solve it before he released the solution.
Uh, cause I had a really busy week, but, uh, this is definitely a really cool, a really
cool payload.
Um, did you see it?
It's in the doc.
Yeah, I did.
I did.
So I spent a bunch of time looking at this and I was, I was going down that right down
like the right path actually, because I noticed, um, uh, like I, I noticed right away that in
the escape for regex function.
Yeah.
Uh, and this will make more sense if you've actually looked at the challenge, but there's
essentially two parts, right?
There's escape for regex and escape for HTML and the escape for regex takes in like the
regex parameter name and then escapes it.
So it could be used as a regex and then the escape for HTML takes the value escapes it.
So it can be used in HTML, puts it in the HTML, um, does like a match and replace.
And I had noticed pretty early on that there was some really weird.
Replace.
They were using a very strange syntax.
Okay.
They were using backslash dollar sign ampersand.
And I, I was like, what the fuck is that?
Like that, that's like super weird.
And so I actually, I looked into it and I found, oh, you know, it, it references, uh,
it references some like, uh, w what, what was it?
It's like the last, it's a syntax language for, um, replacing things.
The match substring.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So if you're familiar with regex, you probably know that like dollar sign number is very common
for replace groups.
Like if you, if you have select groups, dollar sign zero is the whole match.
Dollar sign one is the first group.
Dollar sign two is the second group.
Dollar sign three is the third group.
So on.
Uh, but I had never seen dollar sign ampersand or any of these, these other ones.
I only knew about the indexes.
Yeah.
Um, and for named groups, you can also do like dollar sign, uh, with like a name, uh,
if you have a name on it's assigned with the group, but that's also a less common syntax.
Yeah.
And, uh, that was kind of as far as I got, like I'd spent a bunch of time looking at,
um, you know, possible, like how it was escaping and all that kind of stuff.
I had a suspicion that potentially there was something with the regex, but I didn't really
go down that.
And then I got sidetracked and never really got to finish it.
And so when I saw that, he tweeted out the hint and was like dollar sign, I was like,
okay, for sure.
This is something with the regex.
I just don't have time to do this, but that kind of confirms my suspicion.
And then he, he came out with the hint.
And, um, when I saw what the intended solution was, it, it, it caught me off guard again because
it was not just a dollar sign, but also like another nuance.
And so it was, it was very cool.
He linked out to, um, the Mozilla JavaScript reference docs.
Yeah.
And, um, there's this section called specifying a string as the replacement.
And this is on the string dot replace like prototype function docs.
Um, and it says that there's these different patterns, dollar sign, dollar sign for a dollar
sign literal dollar sign, ampersand for the match substring dollar sign back tick for the
portion of the string that precedes the match substring.
Dollar sign apostrophe for the portion of this, the string that follows the match substring.
And then dollar sign N for the numbers.
Like we talked about in dollar sign name for named groups.
Yeah.
It's kind of crazy.
I was just like so much functionality here.
It's like, what the heck?
Yeah.
So I, I really, I haven't gotten to mess with this yet, but did you, did you mess with it?
I, I, I messed with it a ton.
And, and well, after he released the solution and I was like, wow, this is super cool.
And whenever I see this sort of thing, it makes me think like, how can I look at this exploit,
this specific scenario where this worked and try to apply this to a bigger concept or idea.
Yeah.
And I, and I, and the thing that kind of came to mind was this is like input modification or input expansion, right?
Like how can you take your user input and, and get it to do something different or do something?
Um, what am I trying to say?
Or to modify the content of that.
And we see this all the time when you're bypassing sanitization.
Um, you know, we see this when there's modifications being done or functions being called on your input
after a certain check is being done, you know, something like that.
Those are common patterns.
And this as well, you know, anytime your input is being placed into a scenario where it's being used as, um,
a modifier.
Yeah.
As a modifier or as like almost like code, right?
It's like a pseudo code.
It's, it's not really code, but it's like, uh, um, B could be interpreted as string or it could be interpreted as code.
You, you need to look at those situations very closely because there's almost always some weird shit that can go on.
Yeah.
Cause I like, I think if you look at this challenge, like in retrospect, um, like obviously like I knew from the very beginning, like this isn't gonna require me to find a zero day in Google tag manager.
Like for, for sure.
Like there's not like, he's not hinting at a zero day.
This, this is using the latest version.
Like it's gotta be something about the implementation.
That's one of the advantages about CTFs and like challenges like this in general, that, you know, there's a solution.
So the question is like, what are you missing?
Mm-hmm .
And that gives you more opportunities to sort of think creatively, uh, which is what I really liked about these types of things.
Yeah.
Think critically.
Um, but I will say like, definitely your Spidey sense probably should have been triggered a little bit.
If when you were looking at like how this is working and seeing that it was taking your input and making a regex out of it.
Well, it's pretty much the only functionality on the page.
The, the script is only like what?
35, uh, you know, lines long.
And when you look at it, everything else is pretty standard.
Right.
You know, there's like 10 lines that go to like parsing out a query string and that sort of thing.
So pretty much the only weird part of this situation is, uh, the replace function.
Um, and, and I guess we, we kind of dove into the details and we didn't give quite as good of an explanation for those of you that haven't seen the XSS challenge.
So if you're still hanging in, you know, in there with us at this point, thank you.
But the scenario was that there was a, uh, a script tag that was being dynamically created.
Um, and what ended up happening and they were using match, uh, a string replace in JavaScript.
JavaScript for it.
And, um, what ended up being the, the, the problem with this is this whole concept of being able to inject these, uh, what are they called?
Like group modifiers or into the replace, the replace portion of them replace call.
Um, which will allow you to take the preceding bit of what actually was being matched.
So in this scenario, that was a script tag that had access to the double quote character.
So when you put that in that same double quote that was proceeding, your user input would get put into the replace text.
And then that, that would create that would break out of the HTML attribute context and give you the ability to insert a arbitrary HTML attribute, which led to XSS.
Um, right.
So really crazy.
It's super interesting.
Yeah.
Like when I write it, Red X, I've definitely come across an instance where I, I understand why this exists, you know, because oftentimes you'll try and match something before a group or whatever.
And like, maybe you need to know what that is.
So you'll put it in a separate group and then you just reference it by its index or whatever.
But instead this essentially takes the default behavior that you can have a red X that matches a whole string, but also has groups within it.
And you can get, you know, a portion before that, like before that, Matt, it it's, it's a very niche use case, but I can understand why it exists.
And, uh, I'm definitely gonna have to look at some of the books I've submitted.
Cause I think that.
Yeah.
Well, it, it, it, it underlies, you know, it emphasizes one of the things that we've talked about here often, which is red X.
They're used all the time for security and they're very hard to make properly secure.
So really knowing your reject stuff inside, outside, upside down in, in PHP and JavaScript and Python and all of these various languages, all of them have different quirks.
And, uh, this whole concept of, you know, getting control or being able to inject the pre match.
String and the post match string and that match string in the result of a, of a replacement is something that you'll also see in other languages.
other languages.
Um, and it's something that is more widely applicable to regex in general.
Uh, so whenever these, these sort of techniques come out, you gotta go back and look at, okay, what reports have I submitted that have anything to do with regex and how can I go back and re break it again?
Yeah, exactly.
And there's always like, um, you know, it's good to, to, to know about these things because some of these things are changes within like how the default functionality works.
These are improvements or, or things that, you know, maybe this didn't, I don't know when this was introduced, but,
um, I'm sure this didn't exist for a period of time.
And so now it's been introduced.
And, uh, now it's just something that you have to sort of keep an eye out for and be like, okay, this, I know, I know now that like you can do this, you know, put that in, in my notebook for later.
It's so common to like this sort of templating thing where you're taking user input and you're using it to replace a, a placeholder in a template.
Right.
Like that happens all the time.
It's not like some weird scenario where, uh, you know, the user's input is almost never placed in the actual, you know, replace the regex of the, of the regex, um, match and replace.
So anytime there's, there's templating, this is something I'm going to keep in mind because the context is so important in those scenarios and being able to inject everything before, uh, your match.
And it's not even that, that, that pre pended string is a part of the match.
It's not, it's just before the match.
So it's, it's very odd.
And I think it'll break a lot of stuff.
So shout out to Franz for an amazing challenge.
This one really, this one was really superb as the only word I can come up with for it.
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah.
This is a very, very cool one.
I liked it a lot.
Um, all right, let's, uh, let's take a look at the next one here.
Yeah.
Oh man, this is, this was nuts.
Um, this is the hacker one disclosed, uh, 25 K crit, um, which is kind of nuts.
This is one of the things you think you'll probably never see.
And then you see it, um, what, what day was this, that they released this, uh, December
8th hacker one disclosed a critical SSRF on the analytics report functionality in hacker
one.
Um, and essentially this was, I mean, not to underscore or not to, um, you know, undermine the coolness
of this vulnerability.
Cause it was very cool, but it was pretty much a textbook.
Uh, PDF render injection.
And he was able to inject a, I frame in a, in a PDF renderer.
And that I frame was able to point to the AWS metadata and pull AWS credentials and just.
Get access to everything.
Um, and I just, I don't know, man, I feel like I would have, I would have probably not looked
for this as much on hacker one because of how crazy a bug this is.
And you would assume that they'd have their bases covered, but I guess that's not the case.
Yeah.
I mean, if you, it's kind of wild because if you look at, I don't know if you expanded like
the full submission, all the activity to look at what the actual report was, but like, you
literally just, you know, you create a new report, you choose some filters and then in
the template, uh, or yeah, you go to the analytics and you go to create a new report.
And then in the, in the template thing, you just, you know, you put, you just HTML injected
it's, it's GG, you know, like, yeah.
Yeah.
It's a, it's super, super crazy.
I actually, this is really interesting because I was looking at this functionality not long
ago.
No way.
Oh, I hate that.
Definitely after the, no, no, definitely after this was reported though.
It wasn't, it wasn't, uh, it wasn't before November 23rd when this was first submitted,
but I was looking at this function.
I was like, that's kind of weird.
Why does it do that?
Um, that makes a lot of sense.
This is really interesting.
Yeah.
Dude, the fact that they was able to get an iframe in there is kind of crazy.
And you look at the explainants, like, he's like, all right, Etsy password, we're
going to hit, uh, you know, 169.254.169.254.
He's just like going at it.
And then the funny thing too, is if you look at the comment, he says, I sent a message 10
minutes ago to all of these triagers and he just pings all of the triagers.
Yeah.
Think of, which is amazing.
Um, but I mean, I would, I would too, man, I'd be pinging people right off the bat if I
submitted something like this.
So it just goes to show, man, like even, even crazy security oriented companies that
have had this type of bug reported multiple times on their own platform, um, you know,
can make these sort of mistakes as well, because not all the developers are tied into this and
what kind of becomes, um, everyday stuff for us, uh, doesn't necessarily become that sort
of thing for all the developers, even in a security oriented organization.
So it's, it's encouraging to see.
And it, it makes you, it kind of, um, refreshes the, the knowledge that everything's vulnerable.
It just takes time, you know?
Yeah.
For sure.
So cool.
Yeah.
It's always, it's always nice.
And I love that they disclose all that kind of stuff too.
Yeah.
That one must've been a hard one for hacker one to disclose.
I don't know if they, if they like to disclose that sort of thing.
I, you know, it seems to me that they try to try to put forth that, that, uh, you know,
precedent for the rest of the programs and stuff like that.
But I'm sure Gilbert, when he saw that report kind of cringed a little bit thinking, all right,
gotta, gotta send that one to the rest of the folks.
But no, it's good.
It is good that they do that.
Um, next I had on the list here, uh, and I'm really excited about this one.
Kaido has finally finished the, uh, issue that I submitted months ago.
And I, I, I guess I sort of cheated the system a little bit on this one.
I submitted an issue to Kaido saying, Hey, I'd really like the search tab to be reworked.
And they're like, okay, well, you know, we, we prioritize the issues by upvotes.
So, uh, we'll, we'll get to it if, if it gets upvoted.
I'm like, Hmm, I think I know some people that would like to upvote this.
And so I ended up like tweeting out and calling on some of the critical thinking listeners
to go upvote it.
And all of a sudden it like skyrocketed to the top of the upvoted list to get a cool search
functionality included into Kaido, which is a very needed functionality, I think.
Um, yeah.
And they did it.
Yeah.
They prioritized it.
Um, Kaido now has this really awesome, easy to use just search bar.
Um, and it's got also a wire shark esque query language associated with it, where you can
query specific parts of the request, um, in this URL bar and this sort of search bar, um,
inside of, of Kaido.
So I was really hyped about that.
I've been using it a lot and it's been mega helpful.
And man, the only thing they need now is, is plugins.
And then I'll be sated for a little while.
I won't be knocking on their door every day being like, Hey, where's my feature?
Where's my feature?
So.
Yeah, dude.
Uh, I just need better scope management.
That's like.
Scope management of plugins.
Let me, let me, let me, let me add a caveat to that, man.
They messaged me after we had, we talked about that on the pod.
I don't know if we've released that episode yet or not, but, um, and they said, dude,
we, you can do that.
It's just star the, the word that you want star.
And I tried it and it works.
It doesn't say it in the little documentation.
No, apparently it's been like that for a while and they don't say it in the little
documentation.
If you click the little question mark next to that section in the preset scope, uh,
area, but, um,
I had tested that and it wasn't like that.
So I think that might be, might be a bit of a change, but it used to be that like,
cause I have a habit of when I add a domain, I do like say it's example.com.
I had example.com just by itself.
And then I had star.example.com and that catches both like root domain.
And then like any of the subdomains under it.
Cause sometimes you'll go to example.com and it'll send you to www.example.com.
I thought you were doing just example star, you know?
No, I mean, now I will.
Yeah.
Now I'm going to do it just like I do in burp.
Cause now.
Oh, that's what you were doing in Kaido.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
No, that makes sense.
It, it, you should be able to do the same thing that you're doing in burp now in
Kaido, uh, with just star word star, and that will give you anything that has the
word in the host name.
Um, so that's a big improvement.
I I'm happy to see that.
So, uh, it looks like the wishlist for both of us now is kind of down to those
plugins.
So it will be great to have some Python plugins though.
I love, I love a good extensibility.
Yeah, for sure.
And I'm looking and yeah, definitely.
Joel is distracted.
It works.
Okay, great.
That's good.
I like to see it.
Well, that's awesome.
Awesome stuff from the Kaido team.
I, uh, I like, I like to see when stuff works.
So yes, that's definitely, that's definitely awesome.
Good shit, man.
Cool.
All right.
Let's jump over to the last thing on the news.
Um, we had the blind, not blind, I almost said blind XSS.
It's blind CSS exfiltration research released by Portswigger.
And once again, I just want to, I just want to say just because I'm a Kaido fanboy and I
love Kaido doesn't mean I have anything against Portswigger as a company, their product.
It's heavy.
You know, it requires a lot of, uh, RAM, but it's amazing.
And, and burp is a phenomenal tool and Portswigger research is so great.
Um, and this time around it was Gareth, uh, releasing a blind CSS injection tool, which is
such an interesting concept and a relatively new, I guess, attack vector or vulnerability
type, not, not something that I've heard about before this, uh, this writeup, uh, where he
releases a tool for essentially being able to do for, it's like what XSS Hunter is, but
for CSS and being able to exfiltrate the contents of various input fields and text areas and that
sort of thing.
Uh, and the writeup is really detailed and includes a lot of, um, I guess, sort of research mentality
in there as well, which is something we really like to see about how he figured out how many,
um, input fields there are by using the has and not selectors in CSS, and then the chaining
that together with, uh, the, what is it?
Uh, sick cyclical import chain.
I want to say it's called technique, uh, sort of coined in my mind by donut.
I'll, although there's another researcher, Pepe Villa that has also, uh, released something
almost the exact same time as donut about, uh, CSS exfiltration, um, and using the import,
uh, sort of directive in CSS to, along with some delaying and responding to HTTP requests
in order to create a chain where you can exfiltrate data very quickly and effectively out of, um,
CSS via CSS out of input fields.
So really cool research here.
You love to see it.
Uh, and I'm excited to give it a shot.
I haven't used the blind, uh, CSS.
I almost said blind XSS again, cause it's just a habit.
The blind CSS exfiltrator yet, and I'm sure the use cases are pretty niche, but I guarantee
you will see this at a life hacking event sometimes cause people always come up with the craziest
shit.
Yeah.
No, dude, this is a, I love this research.
This is such a, such interesting stuff.
It's awesome.
They actually shouted out to donut and Pepe Villa, um, in the, in the, uh, in the research
that this was, uh, you know, this sort of, this technique, um, was based on that, that sort
of work, uh, the import chaining stuff.
So it's very, very, very cool.
Um, I think CSS, I, I mean, you can kind of tell based on how Gareth has been doing CSS
research for the past, like two years, that CSS is definitely an unexplored territory and
there's a lot of really interesting stuff there and they keep adding functionality too, right?
They keep making it easier.
They're adding more selectors to do different things with CSS instead of having to use SCSS
or, uh, what, what's the other, what, I don't know, you know, yeah, but yeah, it's a, it's
really, really cool stuff.
I love this, this kind of research.
So I've, I've, as on the note of CSS sort of features expanding, I've got a couple areas
in my pocket where, cause I was doing some CSS based stuff as well when I was doing the post
message based CSS injection to credit card exfiltration exploits.
I've got a couple areas, uh, on high impact programs where I can inject CSS in an, in like
a credit card number context.
Uh, but I don't have all the gadgets I need to fully exfiltrate the card data.
So I'm just waiting and waiting and waiting.
There are a couple key features that I need CSS to release before I can actually start to
exfiltrate that data.
So I've been keeping a close eye on the CSS change logs because I know they're going to
come out and some of the stuff, one of the things, keys I can think of in particular, they say that
they're going to release it.
And I'm just like, when please release it for Christmas, please.
So that's funny.
There's some large companies out there who are sweating bullets right now.
And just knowing that their, their credit card flow is insecure.
I'm just waiting for the CSS release.
Yep.
All right, man.
Um, so that's it for the news this time.
And what I was thinking for the rest of the show is to talk a little bit about the past
year in bug bounty for the both of us, how our stats kind of landed.
Um, if we're satisfied with our performance over the past year, and also talk about some
of the top earning bug classes that we were able to identify, and then also sort of go
after some goals for the new year.
I, I, I'm a little bit of a, uh, some people say, you know, you shouldn't talk about your
goals and stuff like that in public before you accomplish them, because you get that sort
of adrenaline hit by saying, all right, I'm going to do this, you know, and that kind of
takes away from the motivation.
But I, I kind of, I kind of get the opposite, I'm like, if I call my shot, then I gotta,
I gotta do that, you know?
And, uh, yeah.
And so it's a little bit scary to come on a podcast, you know, with several thousand people
listening every week and, uh, and sort of talk about it, but we'll, we'll see, we'll
see how it goes.
I've got, I've definitely got some stuff I want my, I've got my eye on, and I think is
the most effective way to accomplish my bug bounty goals.
But we'll see if that changes as we, as we get into the new year.
Um, but first let's do the year in review.
Um, do you want to go first or should I?
Yeah, sure.
We'll, we'll start small here because I'm not the full-time hacker.
You are.
So yeah, so I, um, my breakdown was, um, I submitted just under 25 reports, uh, 23 reports this year,
which is pretty good.
That's, you know, about one every two weeks, give or take.
Um, so, you know, that's, that's pretty solid, uh, considering I work a full-time job.
Yeah.
Um, you've had a busy year too.
Promotion.
Yeah.
Crazy busy year, all sorts of crazy things.
So many weddings and stuff like that.
Yeah.
Two cats and under you.
Um, yeah.
So 30% crits, 17% high, 34% medium, 13% low, 4% none.
So yeah, I'm about even between highs and crits or sorry, between mediums and crits, which kind
of tells me that basically I either end up in the middle or I end up way at the top.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So, so that's kind of interesting.
Um, maybe it would be good to spend some time trying to focus on seeing if I can get
some more of those highs next year's cause I mean, high payouts are usually still quite
good.
Yeah.
Um, so, you know, it's not, not all about focusing on that.
I think this makes sense too, because a lot of times when you look for critical vulnerabilities,
you, and, but there's some like major.
Pre-condition that's needed or mitigating factor, you land at a medium instead of a high, which
is a little bit of a shame, but it is something that you see pretty often.
So it makes, that makes sense to me that about those would be about even cause about half the
time they're going to have some weird thing that you can't quite work around or, or even,
you know, when we work together, um, you know, there's some, some preconditions that
were required for some exploits that we just really couldn't work around.
And cause you can't really do anything if you don't have access to functionality.
And sometimes that functionality is gated behind, you know, uh, privileges or something
like that.
So.
Right.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Um, so the breakdown for what type of engagements these are mostly on, um, it was basically
50, 50 for me, I'm excluding some of the smaller stuff, but it was essentially 50% bounty
programs and 50% challenge programs.
Uh, which is going to be like live hacking events, H1Cs, the maybe, I don't know if pen
tests are included in that.
Maybe, maybe not.
I don't think so.
I don't, I don't know.
Um, but yeah, about 50, 50 between live hacking events and bounty programs, which is pretty much
expected for me.
That's basically all I do for bug bounty is that.
And then pen tests is, is the little bit of the portion that's on the side.
That's probably not in there.
Yeah.
So I, I guess that's, that's true.
Pen tests are not probably included in these stats, which is interesting.
I, I haven't done many pen tests, but I know you do them on a pretty regular basis, right?
Yeah.
I try and, um, keep them going on somewhat of a regular cycle.
It's just a good, you know, you can do them at the same time as you do bounty stuff.
If you have, uh, um, the, the, the capacity for it.
And I think it's a good source of income.
Like, even if you're just a pen tester and let's say you book them back to back every
two weeks, uh, I want to say the pay is let's, you know, it's a couple thousand dollars per
pen test, uh, per person.
So if you, you know, multiply that twice a month, 24 a year, you know, uh, even if it's,
you know, $2,000 per pen test, right.
That's almost 50, uh, almost 50 K a year.
Right.
So that's awesome.
Um, it's, it's a good amount of side income if you can do them all the time.
Yeah.
That's, that's great, dude.
I'm, I'm, uh, yeah, I think the other thing that comes to mind on this sort of thing is
that you've mentioned in the past that you feel like the areas that you research take
a lot of upfront investment.
So it's not as easy for you to just kind of hop in and say, all right, I've got three
hours.
Let me go find a buck.
You know, it's more like, all right.
Um, I'm going to hack this target now.
This is going to be my thing for the next two weeks.
Uh, and, uh, I'm only going to think about that and that's going to be my life.
You know?
Yeah.
One of the interesting things I've noticed about my hacking style is that like, it's not,
it's not so much like, like the bounty is cool and stuff, but I'm more enticed by the challenge.
And so when I see something that's like been set up to be challenging, that's what really
will get me.
Like, I want to get around that.
So a good example, and this is a public program, Hyatt.
Um, Hyatt is, uh, they have a, they pay pretty well.
It is.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
Let's see what else we got.
Did you?
Yeah.
Let me let me I'll talk about this next one and then we'll kind of go back and forth because
I've got a couple more than yours.
So the next one I have on my list is non-traditional automation stuff that I'd like to do in 2024 and that includes JS monitoring which is something we've talked about a lot here to kind of alert when new features are being added to applications that you already have a large context for.
And source code monitoring for things that you actually have the source code for which I think will be really big for me if I can identify some vulnerable patterns in open source software that's being either propagated to a bunch of companies or is actually have having a bug bounty program themselves.
Then I think that could be a source of semi passive income where it's like hey there's very likely a bug here.
Go check it out and it takes maybe an hour to exploit it and you can get a report out of it.
But it's not you know the traditional subdomain takeover or whatever XSS that you see in automation.
Yeah dude I feel like that that kind of that kind of pipeline is like really really useful really really useful for for those who don't see the cat bagel Miss bagel is climbing on me right now.
Very cute very cute.
Very cute cat trying to nap.
Yes but no I think that that kind of pipeline is very very almost necessary for full time hackers because the reality is if you don't have something like that then you're going to be spending time looking for things to hack.
And that takes time which takes away from your marketing.
Right.
And so like if like if you don't spend some time building an automation or some sort of monitoring or whatever that's like constantly feeding you new things to look at then you're going to have to take your own time out of your hacking or extra time right where you could be making money to go then find those targets or spend time looking at those things and tracking down those signals.
And you know it just makes it a whole lot easier for you to have basically like a little assistant kind of who's just like hey take a look at this take a look at that.
And sort of refreshing your context too because we kind of talked about that before as well of like you kind of lose context for a specific program after a little while.
But if you've written if you've taken notes with code that was one of the big takeaways that I had from Sam Herb's episode was if you've taken notes with code and you've said hey there was a reason why I thought that it was really important that this I should alert on this specific code.
You should alert on this specific string and then those neural pathways refire a lot more quickly and you can get right back into where you were versus if you're coming in with no context.
So that's something I'm currently doing on a couple programs but the pipeline isn't like fully built out and sometimes my scripts kind of flake out or whatever.
So that's something that I'll be doing more of in 2024 and getting a good pipeline in place for.
Yeah.
All right.
What's the next one on your list.
I wanted to be more consistent with reports and hacking.
I think we talked about that I'm about you know what every two weeks right now.
I think I'd like to get that more just in general across the board.
I'd like to be doing more hacking submitting more reports looking at more stuff.
It's very difficult to find the time and the energy with all the things I have going on to sit down and like spend some quality time hacking and finding bugs.
I find that a lot of the time I'm just kind of like looking at stuff and noticing interesting things but it takes a little bit more to get it to sort of that end point.
Yeah.
So I'd like to be a little more consistent on that for sure.
Consistency as a part time hunter is difficult because it ebbs and flows with your job, with your personal life, with all this other stuff.
And the next one on my list is trying to accomplish all of this like lofty goals stuff that I've got for the podcast and for bug bounty hunting in normal business hours in an eight hour day.
Because here's what I've come to realize Joel is like you can accomplish really amazing stuff if you work 80 hours a week and it's not that hard.
You know, besides that, besides the working 80 hours a week part, which is, you know, just physically and sort of mentally challenging.
If you're working double the amount as other people, you're going to have crazy, you know, oversized results, right?
And that's just kind of to be expected and not that crazy.
The crazy thing to me is when people work less than other people or less than expected and still get outsized results, right?
So that's kind of something that, and that kind of shows that you've really got your system down or you're really looking at something differently, you know?
Or you got really lucky.
Or you got really lucky, right?
Which I feel like that's the case every single time I submit a bug, but the data would suggest otherwise considering either that or I'm the luckiest human on earth.
And so for me, 2024, I want to limit that and really just work within a certain period of time.
Whether it be a sliding eight hour window or, you know, a flexible eight hour window, whatever it is.
And then just work more efficiently and still accomplish great results within that timeframe.
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
I think that's a really interesting takeaway is like, you know, what you mentioned is that like being able to do the same thing that other people do in less amount of time means that you can do more than them or you can make more than them or whatever.
Like, and that's a really like if you can figure out how to optimize what you're doing to do in less time.
That's huge, right?
So I love that.
I feel very similarly, which is like I'm doing a ton of things and generally I'm pretty good about like getting it within work hours.
But I also feel like the burden of doing all those things makes it very challenging to keep all of them going at the same time.
So maybe it's, you know, rebalancing them to do them on certain days instead of everything every day or whatever it is.
You know, I'm not quite sure, but I think it's definitely something to be worked on.
Yeah.
And just for those of you listening that might feel like you haven't achieved this sort of success that you're looking for, whether it be in bug bounty or career and stuff like that.
One, one tip that kind of goes contrary to what we're talking about right now is that if really you just want the success, one of the best ways to get that is just put in more time, you know, and you got to decide whether that's going to be healthy for you or whether you're in a position in life where you're going to benefit from that.
Um, and whether that's actually what you want with your goals.
Uh, but if you're really just looking for success, you can probably find that by doing it more.
And I've noticed this in multiple areas of life, you know, um, not just bug bounty, but fitness as well was one of the other ones.
I was like, I used to be doing a three by five program where I would do three sets of five reps and when I, once a week, but then I switched to twice a week, five by five.
And I noticed the results dramatically changed just cause I'm, I'm pushing more weight and I'm spending more time doing it, you know?
Um, and so I think that's another hack, but obviously comes with at the cost of a bunch of time and effort.
So, yeah, yeah.
Um, the next thing I had on my list was I want to hack more IOT stuff or I want to do more hardcore source code review.
And those are not entirely disjointed from each other, but I'll just say, Joel, that I'm going to do more hardcore source code review.
I'll just say Joel, that experience that we had of hacking, uh, on that live hacking event together earlier this year.
Um, and we just had like this massive Python code base and we were just tearing it apart and finding all the sources and sinks.
And even now with, with, uh, the word fence stuff we've done over the past couple of weeks doing a lot of PHP source code review and that sort of thing.
Um, I just realized how much I love actually having source code.
It's, it's phenomenal, you know?
Okay, dude, I have a, I have a program for us.
What have you got?
I've been, I've been working on something.
Can you say it?
Uh, okay.
Do you, do it?
I can, I don't know if we should.
No, no, no, no.
Don't say it.
Cause I'd like to work on it with you.
All right.
But it's a public program, but yeah.
Oh, all right.
Well, we'll see how it goes.
I, I would definitely like to do more of that.
And I love the concept of IOT stuff being where like you dump the firmware and then you get the source code and now you're doing source code review.
That's the ideal situation.
But this is going back to what we were talking about before.
IOT stuff, the bounties aren't good enough relative to the time you have to invest.
Really, IOT bounties need to be high, high five figures to make it worth the time.
If you're, if you're a decent web hunter, right?
Cause you can go to programs like PayPal and Shopify where they're paying massive bounties for web stuff, you know,
and, and find stuff quicker than you would on an IOT based program.
And it's easier, you know, and your eyes aren't bleeding and you're not having to fight with hardware.
And there's not a bunch of setup without the thought of return on investment.
So I think IOT space needs to expand its bounties and, and pay a little bit more into the five figure range and some even in the six figure range to see the real big sort of attraction from other hunters that have diverse skill sets as well.
So one of those two will be good.
And then this is the other thing that I wanted to talk about.
And this is kind of a, I think probably something that you and I both have on our, our goals for 2024 would be this concept of influence.
And this is the concept of influencing tool creation or influencing the sort of development in the industry that we'd like to see that we don't necessarily have time to do.
Right.
So I've just been really blown away by how awesome the critical thinking community is and how you guys have taken a lot of the ideas that we've presented here on the podcast and actually turn them into tools.
And I think that that's something that could be scaled well, you know, like we, us mentioning these sorts of things, us having sort of the inside scoop from a lot of top hunters.
Taking it to the podcast, giving it to the public and then the public turning this into actual actionable tools that can be used by all hackers and making it a little bit more accessible.
So that's something I definitely want to keep doing in 2024.
Yeah, for sure.
Same here.
You know, I, I want to, I want to keep working on that.
All that kind of like influencing influencer.
Positive change.
This is like a whole new.
Yeah.
Like there's, this is a whole new space, I think for both of us.
So it's, it's definitely been interesting.
All the stuff that we've learned in the last year.
Um, and influencing, you know, kind of has a little bit of a negative connotation, but, but really at the end of the day, it's, it's educating, you know, it's sharing knowledge, right?
Which is what, uh, that this whole content creation thing is about is like coming on here, giving that knowledge, giving that.
Okay. So there's the knowledge piece and there's also the energy piece, right?
Because, you know, you can come in here and man, like sometimes I've been on this podcast and I'm like freaking grabbing my mic so tight and I'm like yelling into the microphone.
Cause I'm so hype about these sorts of things.
Um, and that's great.
That's great to share with the community and the community has shared with me that, that, that is a source of a lot of, a lot of energy, um, for them and, and can, can lead to the development of some really awesome tools that I've, that I've seen.
So, uh, definitely excited for that.
Yeah. Yeah, absolutely.
And the, and the last thing on mine was, uh, I w I want to hack more web stuff, honestly.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
So we're, you know, I like, I have some web stuff.
Yeah.
It's, we are basically flipping cause I've done, you know, a lot of IOT stuff.
I do source code review, like all the time, like it's all mobile.
It's just like reading code.
And like, I've done a lot of that kind of stuff.
And, um, it's not that I'm bored of it.
It's just that like, I, I want to do new stuff, you know, I want to learn new things.
I want to get better.
I want to get better at stuff.
Like I see, I feel like there is a, a, a part of like, there's a, there's a, a, a whole bunch
of vulnerabilities that I am not good at.
Um, that I'd like to be better at.
And I haven't been good at them because yeah.
And the web space, just cause like, I don't do them as much.
Like I don't exploit them as often.
I'm not looking at those technologies as often.
So it's just something that I'm not as familiar with.
And, um, I definitely would like to like to get there with it.
So, man, well, we can, we can trade a little bit.
I, I feel comfortable with almost every, you know, web-based vulnerability that I can, I I'm aware of.
Um, and so we can, we can trade off knowledge there and you can teach me how to do some good source code review and, and, uh, and IOT hacking.
Absolutely.
Should be great, man.
All righty, dude.
I think that's a wrap.
You got anything else you want to say before we kick it to 2024?
No, you know, honestly, this was a great year.
Um, thanks to everybody for listening to the podcast, being with us on this, on this, uh, this first year.
It's been really exciting and I'm looking forward to what happens next year.
Yep.
Same, same here.
I really appreciate the community and, uh, thanks for, thanks for a great year, critical thinking listeners.
Yeah.
See you guys.
Peace.